welcome welcome back to cbs this morning
as we speak
rescuers are getting ready to go inside
a ship that capsized off the louisiana
coast that search for survivors has
lasted for two and a half days
already our lead national correspondent
david begno is in new orleans david
good morning to you so you're telling us
there is still hope that some missing
crew members
may be alive and possibly in the ship
yeah tony and here's what it's based on
tuesday when the ship capsized
the coast guard dropped five life
jackets and five radios down to five men
that they saw on the ship
and the last radio transmission was from
two of the men who said we're going back
into the hall of the ship
so right now we're told that divers are
at the ship they're going to try and
make
access entry into that hole there could
be pockets
inside of there in the living quarters
area where some of those men are still
alive
i heard from someone that
was was rescued that they are in the
boat
all 12 members should be on that boat
waiting to be rescued in in the rooms
with the air
this is marion kyler she's the fiance to
missing crew member chaz morales
she's holding out hope that those
missing might be in sealed
airtight pockets inside the boat two
of the members that are on the boat were
in the engine room which is up
at the top by the water but it's not
clear if anyone inside
is alive these photos show coast guard
crew members
throwing hammers at the capsized lift
boat
in an effort to contact any survivors
divers
also tapped the hole but they never
heard any responses
he just really needs to be i can't go
without him
it's how i feel with a rosary wrapped in
her hand
hannah despot is keeping vigil waiting
for news about her husband dylan
the father of three is one of the twelve
missing crew members that was on the
c-corps power boat
dylan turned 30 on sunday you know
daspit is not waiting alone there are
other family members gathered at a
firehouse near port fuchsia in louisiana
and some of them have been there since
tuesday i don't want to leave until we
have some type of
answer dylan daspit's father scott
decided he was done waiting
he chartered a boat on his own and went
out to find his first born son
he's got the spirit to make it but i
just like to know if he's on the water
i'm going to find him
and he's got a one-year-old and a
two-year-old
loved their daughter very much
mr scott daspid got close enough to see
the shipwreck but he couldn't get close
enough to actually help so he came back
on shore
we talked to him last night he said the
coast guard told him when they get into
the hole this morning those divers get
in there
it's going to almost be as if they're
blindfolded and they're kind of going
touching like this
going room to room to see if anyone is
alive you hear the the thunder behind me
the weather has hampered the search
every day since the ship capsized on
tuesday
let's hope the weather holds y'all so
they can finally give these families
some closure today hopefully the word is
everybody's alive yeah
hope is the word of the day david thank
you very much and the lightning yeah you
feel for those families
those waters in the early days were just
treacherous it's the waiting part that
has to be agonizing you just
need to know